why i love consolidating my digital
collections with movies anywhere
over the years many of us have purchased
many blu-rays and dvds
but what happens when you buy digital
movies from multiple places like prime
video or google play
at some point you lose track of all your
movies movies anywhere has solved that
problem by connecting with those
retailers to help consolidate your
digital movies into one place
movies anywhere works with the following
digital retailers
amazon prime video apple tv voodoo
google play
microsoft movies and tv xfinity for
xfinity tv subscribers only
fandango now verizon files tv for
verizon files tv subscribers only
and directv for directv subscribers only
and because let's face it it's all about
the deals
and sometimes you purchase a movie from
one retailer and at other times you
purchase from a different retailer
therefore if you purchase from multiple
digital retailers
your movies are everywhere so with the
help of movies anywhere you can now have
one digital collection
you won't have to keep jumping between
services trying to track down your
purchases
with movies anywhere they all will live
under one roof
which makes tracking down your movies
far easier
movies anywhere also has a clean simple
interface
which makes it easy to use and the
two-way flow
means that your favorite movies are not
only in one collection with movies
anywhere but your purchase and redeemed
movies will also flow out to your
connected digital retailers
so if you want to watch in more than one
place you can
therefore if you find that your digital
purchases have been scattered to the
winds over the years and you'd like to
find a way to get them all in one place
check out movies anywhere dot com you
must also be 13 years or older to sign
up for movies anywhere